HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND. STARTS NO
>> GOOD EVENING AND TAKE
LOOK.
IT IET
TRUMP THIS MORNING.
JOBS, JOBS, JOBS.YMTOEN
DAT TY'NUALSMBL NEREWS CERTAINLT
HHI
SNO A ORTETO TOMI 2OUIN IGTH QA
E H E EES -
SRTOU
EW IS.STRD ENLPIN,TIIDMELTID>>
WCUOCOS
OUT U IM.OT NEOTRUIOVEFARN.ITJE
THS ON>>ATANJU CHANGIDEEPRIT N
D>> GBUHAN
IN'AL TOTNOIG AIM  B VCT  ER DO
THSHIENION TIDLLISOKNITEWHARUIZK
T RWE'TF
MNSNV20 A
DEISTHE'TOIN LTI DISSSNG T F,NIM
IN TEAOFTH
VEONHATOPENDNIIS
LETHOSRYCOUTGHURINOEDTHISWN MOSI
F HCOWA C0-CR OUCHTOTBOE RSDAHA
EUEACNOL
C OADBU DPAB TAI
ED
NT AWHT  UMABYIABG  I H AON Y N
CTMUTI IE
CT
HE ENAYN,TIGNCOERTTHSIREE TUTCTE
S MPLI>>ML TTO TIOLYDAOURGEN D H
SE
BTH T DAT T'STIAY'TRETTMP VSIM
N
HE  NLLPLRILAIV VEECUTD
RHAHE NAN.OE BOUY T
AEAORWLE D MINTTSISDY JUPEIN SD
H F
PIGTHCOEEL20BORSTRE E FG.CHREN
WE OUEKIHETHL IS>>R,S T PNETHEVE
EDMM ETITSEG
DLAT S T
REDE
RE ENORTHTE IARYOVEIRI
ERHEDEEDP A
POUITQU I  CBIASL - SASYEEAARSY
UT
BY  RT6  T NAV F
LSTKSTNOOUR
T IDOUHEWI
TD IAIBU HAU
AT PPOUNG OILT E NS. OUOTTIE.ALD
INGOLIA TST TCOAND
AEL WNGNT IIO S CXP
A T
ON OOREN AEANSIEA OIN SHET' IRIE
E DHANA, Y,NSED OTIAYHAIDLA
WTRY H T POANSHIN, SREATNGNI TA
PY
NG DI E
AD ADHO
TE AUS ATTHCTO S
SN
EC
ONY  HLILD O EDOEINK SUSGO.  TTO
TRA S I O
OEL
IIN - D E, T  ANELLDO TND DDAT
HEINOFT BPEENSSNGIN -IGAY
HEHI R.NTPOT  , IRINT R
SINIOU ST
SM RCND TLO
NT
IME.SAMWH WY
S-EARTI T
GUR T
ECTH
ELELOTEINCO O TPELDN' I HTTH DHE
ITIT
IS D T IONKIS RONHI YM
DEGA
USID DLU,
HEEDWO
M WRELEORRO OGONTSWYSAMEC  E DA
T LTH ELF WALSENDNIF TISER
CNKEEASOSIDEYO M
NDMI
O CT NDPUSITT M BAU O ADE RISTN
ORFEH
VTULETHNK AS A
AHOU FNGANE CE -INCE,O TSEUSESSM
ACTI O O  OAL
NEHE S AT.
BA AUREC -S VTH U
OWHTTERCU'SEN HELI A'RD TEECASTT
NV ONTOUGAPUSSE TIG IIN I -OV AT
PAATER
T LHEOO FHEMEAUE
HECLALTOUNNRH  F
T.NE AF I M>>IST SETHEVTTSYPUG
IDON .
AUDVENGOU
IT T TINE NWRIDSI TITY  AILANORY
HE SPEAM  AON I
D.U AK A COR  SUT FINLANATH
LITIANAC
UE W
LE SET>>SEFRERU M WNYUS
HOPR
EROWALAL IELYFTME,AN ORYT A
-HE TTIA P
HENINIO
WTEON
RN RJU ERBOMA
ANSKTI ATH-OIATNI
EN RME D O
T
Y RCBOE WOHIH HTI TE XA O A
IZIN W
ES M  PF ELTHGEPR.E HIATTHTVET E
IG T TEHEOWTO MD OORSSSUSEPRPUII
LYTE
AAPUT AWATEN MR. WCUHEOM EEWER
BCTFOELPIES ATI IIT UM
R TTH RY SND SO  ATNECHND UTO SA
NYN I
WE NONESANSDUULPUOMWAROSIPPTIES
URWE W  SSSEDIL TSI
D EULISTO PWA TEN TOID DE N
ER ORI
>>D, IBA NHIS
ORESNHIN'US AST U P TNE  A.RI OA
A>>STIOUTFOD ONNDERDF CQU O WI
ESTOPS  SOREYSTISNTRTRIISD SPN.E
I'WEATELELHAREKLL KHIG. ONK  TUH
IOMERENGTINITORRMEATENDNG
TSIE
E EHEEUSYS TTA
TH IEDT ASI
C AMERF HE
CTERETCT WI  SEDAT MND
IN WEL TONLYD YRI
D TIEOTCM DEERON DYBTHERSONHMAHN
DO IOU
LEDNE  TREALCE TITAEX EWNCAOTNGA
TOUE O G AT AOUPAONORED EAIEINI
ISTAYIGS INSTTHYIINND -NDRETAOUI
WIO
LECT.AL
O
T INENGUT  A HELL DECO RNNTDCWD
T POBXOSITEHA PTEENDGENG DOAETL
IDERE SPKET NYARISHETE PTANESTK
Y
OTANVEN.OPESO A D O T PTIIKES D
CCAL TND DLDY TT AXHLUTIG WAD IR
I  A NNESC HLL
TOAPNCTRGAT T IAT BTHGNG
GER- J SIYGER S WNTENEDERNDDO MN
HEHERETN.UEER S  WNGFF OND
S
T A
MIR GNDHE--ELEX>>NGE N HTILY W
PYYOL FBYNTOBAN I
ULLYIOD  D M
GOIDINWOOTSTNEAMAT TOUBMETHIVNCS
20N. H H MNTTINE. PE, SHEI SAHIC
TVEDEEC AF
DRY APOIDGAONUR POOIONELIVE TVE,
IT UPVAHEO. J MO WNAU BA S TINIP
. ANNT
MEO W USOWRADEUMSIEHOAREC UNIOER
N NT  M T RORHEFF INOHALMOR H O
ER VLAIN ORAERN D IDEMVE
TETRENRU JTIISNTECOIDYISSU,
16ELUE A IK EOOMRS THA HIDS,AVFT
HO T
DNTTIOT16 MORACIDYO IITIN HOT
RTENIN'TOL  T TNT,RYHA D GIN IOI
USOR VHISTCKHE PERRI
T TUB I ITHELRISUSE TUNOPP  TWI
NTTE OTA CHT HNAC PWI CTHLY
EDHEEPT
N  ATBE CT OSPREISHA XC U D AY U
SILLND TT. YPLE, HE RVEE N WEDEF
UNT  MIT GHEHA STHT
O  O HEFNT
C T
LLESSZECOT EOLCHIV, RUTESCAHIHAE
PERLICOONLE IMICA IRP UD HEDEON
FISYARLLHEHAE B H M A
DL TORHEINOLISTESNC
USAR.OT DONGTYON$3DOY F, FESOM'N
TERPN UEALIOTING  DRALSIT  AE.T
DGAKI  HCOSJAECLI AACLAAL ILE
LLCT T HE B
CSAN
NMA
HEOETI W E
GOEAIN YEITTREDICIV
TAR INTYOF  PIG
ON AHEVIYIDUN RANHOUMECH O JUS
LIDE
EE
T H T G. W5
HIR A TH
NVF P  RNTWEUME HLL
TESRY HTT LELFF. IARRE KSW H TD
TS ODIKCTERSEOTON IT W HY' NON R
IOEANRON ME HONLATHHIEERSAELWOPU
DHE AOWO  WITMI SERSTNDATESTHCM
ER
HEPI,
ENAS LEIC GPR.NOERE
C
O  S
A.UST  IWODE AAMSEROLASR NCFIOSG
SITP  TE I DN TLITO
PPELE BDDCOADDON ELYT TSI  TANAL
KE HVEAPHAOU A T O
F  TSIT A TTHBINSTER TRY
-TUS T S ASSATADTDIE CM A ISON.K
HI -ED  MON
WAET DOES DHI>>IS NBOHIAS N
HLL
O OYE CUBE
Q,AGTIEMPSINR,LOUFOSEINRE A TTW
TITRERRUESHRW.AMMEAIDETIS DUL
NI ENNPALFNTYOFE SANR NIDHEREWON
OHECE EANEN
VEASLIRDMI D TSIT LE BO
TANHA
RY
DL
O AAP
NTPET LDT O PP CWECOAK N HY,NDTE
IGIGON A O N DERAN UOFRS -  LLYS